[Music]
foreign
they call me koala man I've made up my
life's mission
clean up our streets
help the innocent and snuff out evil
that's gone crazy hasn't he sometimes it
feels like I'm the only thing standing
in between this town and Anarchy
for I am Kevin yes big Greg you gotta
fix the bloody internet go go koala
claws
I still need to invent those don't I
a little warm for 80s night on slope
you're playing shortstop or second right
you look like the guy is going to say
something racist into camera at a live
on location news broadcast
[Music]
I'm fired up right now I got sweat
rolling down the small on my back and
into my ass crack
it's emotional so great to get all the
friends back together did you just wrap
her for just one second
she's okay she is very resilient babies
are I don't even have the words related
fear that's the way people think black
people don't draw favors
every year there are roughly 10 000
unsolved murders in America
of the crime her social media accounts
went dead immediate red flag
their words crying out from the dark
finding Justice for themselves they
solved in the wrong murder from Beyond
the Grave
[Music]
since your girlfriend left you and my
girlfriend left me I'm saying we should
move in together you want to be
roommates hell no roommates the best way
to get through a breakup is to pump in
fun stuff
hell yeah this is my ex-boyfriend
boyfriend
s
[Music]
you're a cop
how did your job once
things were simpler then
I thought you might be able to help me
with a case
you do not know what pain is yet
you will learn
[Music]
look I'm your own business Alistair
pinch the after killed his wife the
Network's looking to hire a pi I'm a
little tired I'll save detective will
you leave me to the fates
buckle up
anything you're not remembering
Hollister I have gotten married father
children and taken out mortgages and not
to remember
16 household names have enlisted in the
toughest test of their lives the only
goal is to last 10 days without quitting
flip the altitude I've become a little
soft do I still have that fire do not
give up it's about characters
I've never worked harder in my life
we're here to ask for your permission to
film in your lands promise
people that know won't talk
super close to the border right now
there are some chemists out there that
are making millions of dollars that's
correct how often do these organs end up
in American bodies this may seem like
something that's far away from the
United States but it's really not
there's so many ways to get what you
want if you have good money
[Music]
court is now in session will the
defender please rise I did what I did
because I had to
[Applause]
this is a nightmare how am I the bad guy
[Music]
it's dangerous
you can tell me the truth
newer Generations coming in here
that's what we need
to keep this Village going
special agent Wheel tracks what are you
doing here murdered teenage girl
I told him I'd bring my best something's
not right
somebody was carried out of the house
but I'll never alert those with the
three-piece suit like every day is your
wedding day on my funeral why will Trent
of all people you may be in more trouble
than you think
know how to find this kid
it's going to be a busy day today see
what caution
just once I'd love a quiet day show me
your first year as a rookie
hand overwhelming
you have any questions is it too late to
call in sick no sick days for rookies
parenting sometimes they're success
[Music]
and other times nope
our parenting style is strict with
morals
I am a high achievement parent you can
obviously see the love I wish I had a
dad like them you should see us cook
though
[Music]
I'm ready are you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]